There's nothing taboo about this.
This is a family like any other.
It's just started a little differently.
Yeah.
I look around the room
and I just see how much love
that Elijah has in his life, you know?
And he's not lacking anything
because he has amazing parents.
And he has an uncle love like no other.
Will lacking any role models at all.
But then. Okay, so I have to ask, though.
I mean, now that there are over
117 kids and counting.
Like what, 12 breaking 13.
That was last week.
It's 14.
14 baking. Okay.
I mean, do you have concerns
that he might not be able to spend
the time that he did with you
and with Elijah?
I mean,
I think obviously
he's not Superman, right?
So he can only spread himself so thin.
But we can't tell him what to do,
what not to do.
I mean, he'll stop at some point, right?
The max is 501 That's the max plan.
Everyone runs absurd.
500. It's not a 501. So
Do we think it's
insane that he has that many kids?
Of course
it's unheard of that one man can see,
you know, over
a hundred children,
but everything is a little bit
different here, you know?
And if he's happy,
if he's happy,
Lee and her family seem happy.
Elaine seems happy.
But I am beginning to wonder,
are you happy doing this already?
On the surface.
Ari seems unfazed by his large number
of offspring,
his life remarkably carefree.
But the joy of being a father to 117
children and counting
doesn't come completely without strings.
So hey, how you doing, Jason?
Rene, go here.
Yeah. Are you.
You got a minute?
I'm having a couple of problems.
Oh, God.
Yeah, I got him in.
What's going on?
Child support, Casey.
That's right. Child support.
You've probably been
wondering about Ari's legal obligations.
For the most part, he has none.
Remember Elaine, mother of Emerson?
This is what she had to say about it.
Did you ever sign paperwork with Ari
about custody or nothing?
I just didn't feel like it was necessary.
So basically,
everything between you and Ari is
on good faith, right?
And that's it.
Ari doesn't usually sign contracts
with the moms he donates to.
And now,
in a few cases, he's on the hook.
So you're paying child support
for some of your kids.
You know,
it wasn't the arrangement initially,
but some of the moms went back
on their word.
Five of them, to be exact.
Ari sends each of those families
a weekly check
and pays for half their child care.
That's still going to be
34% for his day job.
Ari's a college math professor
and that's going to be 2%. Okay.
He makes a decent salary.
$100,000 a year.
But the expenses
are draining his bank account
more than half.
My salary is garnished
from child support.
And unfortunately,
it's part of the reason
I struggle financially so much.
This one's for fortune and $67.
Two different women
and one bill is for 467,
one bills for 665.
But I don't know whose bills whose.
It's an ongoing battle Expensive
and time consuming.
The issue is that the mother
sending the kids to camp,
she's going to hit me up
for half of that.
How long do I have to pay for?
50% of the daycare
to be paying checks until the day
you die.
Before you
while you're going
to have another 40 kids.
And who knows what the result
is going to be over there.
You don't go into it with documentation
or paperwork.
You don't sign anything
or obligate the witness to sign contract.
If they ask me to sign something, I will.
But there's no contract that I could sign
that would either protect them from me
filing for custody
or protect me from child
support obligations.
Those just doesn't exist.
While most states have laws
protecting donors who impregnate women
with the help of a physician,
men like Ari
who donate sperm outside the system
aren't similarly protected.
There's no equivalent to, say,
a prenuptial agreement
that would prevent a mother
from suing him for child support
after the kid is born.
The legislatures
have never
fathomed anybody doing what you're doing.
This is getting out of hand.
This is crazy.
Do you see how these problems
are cropping up?
I mean, you're breaking
a lot of boundaries here
that are inappropriate.
Is this you
as my friend or as my legal advisor?
All right.
This is me as an buddy off the street.
I happen to be
your legal advisor and a friend.
The legal protection
would be of the sector.
That's one option.
Another would be for Ari
to vet the women he's donating to.
Are there women
who you tell or you can't donate to them?
I try and help whoever asks.
It's not really my place to say,
well, let me see
if you're going to be worthy
of being a parent.
They're coming to me.
They want to grow their families.
What would I do Should I run their credit
if it affects your finances this much?
A lot of people would say yes.